[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à Lyon sur la place de mon plaisir
l'inauguration d'un monument aux frères
Lumière en présence d'Henri lumière qui
fut en 1894 le héros inconscient du
déjeuner de bébé ramène l'attention sur
cette invention qui fit depuis pas mal
de chemin le cinéma le monument se
dresse sous les fenêtres de la villa ou
les deux frères d'abord et Auguste salle
après la mort de son frère Louis
travailleur à mettre au point cette
découverte révolutionnaire et à côté des
ateliers où ils industrialisèrent leur
invention détail curieux la vieille
entrée est restée ce qu'elle était
lorsqu'elle servit de décor au premier
film de tous les temps devenu
aujourd'hui une sorte de monument
historique la sortie des usines lumière
Antonin ce premier film Les Frères
Lumière avaient du même coup créé le
film d'actualité celui qui à travers les
grands événements et les détails
quotidiens a pour raison et pour devoir
décrire l'histoire c'est ainsi qu'on
peut retrouver grâce au cinéma du temps
l'atmosphère des inondations de 1910 et
avec ses serres gens de ville moustachu
et ses omnibus achevaux l'ambiance d'un
pari d'avant la guerre de 14
avec ses duels aussi le duel faisant
alors partie de la chronique mondaine
avec ses présentations de mode ou le
Dior de l'époque qui s'appelait Paul
Poiret exhiber des élégances qui ne
contèrent pas pour rien dans les fastes
de la belle époque
[Musique]
on imagine pas de gaieté de cœur nos
belles amies pareillement costumes
[Musique]
et quant au chapeau
mais dans l'actualité on vit encore le
vol du premier Zeppelin les premiers pas
des transports aériens
[Musique]
et gros plan historique la visite à
Berlin d'un Jaurès qui en juillet 1914
voulait encore ne pas croire à la guerre
le 14 à 18 l'actualité connue sur tous
les tranchées une guerre sans panache
avec seulement de la vermine de la boue
et de la mort et la caméra enregistra au
milieu des trous Debus le triste épisode
des gaz asphyxiants
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vin la victoire et l'actualité ce fut
cette page d'histoire
des Champs-Élysées du défilé derrière
Foch et j'offre des armées à liées
le reporter est toujours là aujourd'hui
sur ces mêmes champs élysées il a
enregistré pour le présent et pour
l'avenir le voyage en France du roi Olaf
5 de Norvège
[Musique]
devant la dalle du soldat inconnu le roi
et le général de Gaulle ont pu repenser
à cette fraternité d'armes qui se résume
dans le nom de Narvik
[Musique]
la visite du roi de Norvège devait se
terminer par une sorte d'à côté hausse à
l'Opéra
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
visite de l'amitié à laquelle la France
est sensible une amitié renforcée par
des traités mais aussi par un
attachement commun à la liberté
[Musique]
et la caméra banane est là également
avec les 30 000 spectateurs de Colombes
pour assister à un événement que les
Français attendent depuis 36 ans la
victoire de leurs athlètes sont les
athlètes allemands cette victoire elle
se dessine déjà dès le 100 mètres qui
constitue la revanche des championnats
d'Europe et c'est de la cour qui cette
fois prend le meilleur le sprint
français ne se porte pas mal du tout il
est le meilleur en Europe en cette fin
de saison après le relais quatre fois
100 mètres personne n'aurait osé par
rien sur les chances des Français avant
le départ
[Applaudissements]
et pourtant au dernier relais tout le
stade est debout lorsque Piquemal passe
le témoin de le cours qui file vers la
victoire malgré le retour de l'allemand
Germain
c'est un premier pas vers la victoire
finale plus rien maintenant n'est
impossible aux athlètes français
oublions pas 4 mètres 55 à la perche
après l'allemand Uter au saut en
longueur brachi le français plus il pris
fort plus ils sont loin
[Applaudissements]
le 200 mètres c'est la réédition des
autres épreuves de vitesse on croit que
Piquemal va tout casser il sort du
virage en bolide mais pikma est trop
léger il ne résiste pas au vent dans la
ligne droite dans le courant encore une
fois remporte l'épreuve
[Musique]
de le cours Nantes pour la troisième
fois au fait du podium en 48 heures pour
le 1500 mètres les deux Michels Bernard
et jazzy se sont réconciliés ils ont
décidé de mettre les deux Allemands dans
leur poche pour jadis et facile il est
imbattable il le trouve en démarrant
quand il le désirent et s'il se retourne
plusieurs fois avant l'arrivée c'est
pour être certain que Bernard le suit
Bernard est là les deux Français donnent
le coup de grâce aux Allemands encore
tout surpris d'avoir été battu par la
France
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à Vénissieux monsieur Émile roche
président du Conseil économique à
inauguré le nouveau centre de recherche
des usines berliets à sa suite les
journalistes ont pu découvrir ce qu'on
ne verra pas au Salon de l'Auto le
laboratoire où c'est labore les nouveaux
modèles le temple futuriste ou 600
chercheurs soumettent au pire tyrannie
dans des cellules insonorisées les
organes mécaniques des prototypes en un
mot l'univers de robot et de cadran où
naissent prêts à prendre la route les
modèles de demain
ce qu'on ne verra pas non plus au salon
mais ce qu'on vit nous reporter ce sont
des voitures en action on serait tenté
de dire en vol
une nouvelle formule de présentation qui
se révèle parfaitement apte à démontrer
les vertus de maniabilité et de sécurité
d'une voiture
moniteur de l'école française de
haute-voltige élève du champion du monde
j'en suis José Kanga a fait ainsi la
démonstration qu'il est très facile de
rouler en Simca 1000
réputé gros mangeur de pain le Français
a également pour la science solide
appétit il en consomme 325 kg par an
soit près d'un kilo par jour et ça dire
qu'il s'est découvert une prédilection
pour les plats de clous non bien sûr
mais il s'est trouvé bien d'autres
occasions d'augmenter sa ration
quotidienne sous forme de monnaie par
exemple les nouveaux centimes seront en
acier inoxydable la pièce de 5 centimes
c'est le sous-dotrefois mais en acier
sous toutes les formes qui agrémentent
le confort quotidien cuisine tout acier
par exemple et puis les transports les
wagons ultra modernes qui pour leur
élégance leur propre thé et la sécurité
du voyageur ont été construits en acier
inoxydable le paquebot France à lui seul
a absorbé 34000 tonnes d'acier soit les
trois quarts de son poids total
et puis le bâtiment ou l'acier de plus
en plus utilisé
c'est le gymnase de La Porte d'Ivry
où la nouvelle faculté de droit à Paris
deux exemples parmi tant d'autres qui
traduisent la parfaite adaptation de
l'acier à l'architecture moderne enfin à
origny-sainte-benoît dans l'Aisne les
silos à blé comportent les cellules de
stockage en acier les plus grandes du
monde et l'on prévoit que l'appétit du
français pour l'acier augmentera encore
dans les années à venir
la plongée sous-marine ne date pas
d'hier mais les appareils préconisés au
XVIIe siècle qu'il s'agisse du
scaphandre de Borély ou des systèmes qui
ont suivi ne permettait pas d'excessifs
audaces ce qui n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui ou certains se lancent à
l'aigrement par 40 à 50 mètres de fond
pour la première fois des médecins se
sont réunis pour se familiariser avec
les conséquences possibles des plongées
sous-marines ils l'ont fait en devenant
eux-mêmes au Centre international de
bindor plongeur sous-marin si n'importe
qui peut songer à effectuer des plongées
sous-marines encore faut-il s'y être
entraîné c'est à cette nécessité que
répond l'école de bindorre qui est la
seule du genre et qui enseigne les
rudiments de la plongée par exemple
savoir sans s'affoler enlever son masque
le nettoyer le remettre la follement dès
qu'on a quitté la surface et le pire
ennemi
les grandes plongées du reste ce sont
des plongeurs expérimentés qui les
réalisent à 40 ou 50 mètres sous l'eau
l'aventure sous-marine en dépit de ses
apparences de facilité comportent des
dangers mortels principalement livraises
des profondeurs tout à coup le plongeur
perdant tout contrôle abandonne son tuba
la grande règle de la plongée est de ne
jamais l'effectuer seul une défaillance
solitaire est ici sans remède
quant au remontées elles doivent
s'effectuer par palier pour permettre à
l'organisme de rétablir l'équilibre à
mesure que la pression décroît
[Musique]
faute de quoi seul le caisson de
recompression qui reconstitue
l'opération manquée peut sauver
l'imprudent
il en est dans ce domaine comme dans
bien d'autres et pour qui sait garder
son sang-froid le monde sous-marin
réserve des satisfactions innombres la
sensation d'une nouvelle liberté
le général de Gaulle a expliqué aux
Français sa proposition tendance à faire
élire le Président de la République au
suffrage universel
le projet
que je vous soumets propose
que le Président de la République
votre président
soit élu dorénavant par vous-même
rien n'est plus républicains rien n'est
plus démocratique
j'ajoute que rien n'est plus français
tant cela est clair simple et droit
cette proposition est le recours au
référendum devait susciter une crise
ministérielle le message du chef de
l'État aux assemblées lui au Sénat par
monsieur Marius Moutet doyen d'âge avait
été suivi par l'élection pour la 17e
fois de Monsieur Monnerville à la
présidence de cet assemblée trois jours
avant au Congrès radical de Vichy le
président du Sénat avait pris violemment
position contre cette novation
constitutionnelle
à l'Assemblée nationale au cours d'une
séance dont le président Chaban-Delmas
fut maîtriser les mouvements de fièvre
le long de 25 interventions parmi
lesquels celle de Paul Reynaud et de Guy
Mollet monsieur Pompidou devait être
victime pivotent de censure acquis par
280 voix sur 480 le gouvernement était
donc renversé
le général de Gaulle en suivi pas moins
le programme qu'il s'était fixé comme il
était prévu il alla assisté au manoeuvre
de champagne dont le double but était de
montrer au pays son armée en cours de
reconstruction en métropole et de
replacer les soldats dans la perspective
qui doit être la leur au cours des
prochaines années
dans une forte ambiance atomique comme
dit le programme les troupes des deux
camps rouge et bleu devaient mettre en
action un matériel nouveau entièrement
français et dont l'usage dans les
conditions réelles de son emploi à
passionné les observateurs
[Musique]
c'est sur un sentiment de satisfaction
que le général de Gaulle a qui revient
l'initiative de ces manœuvres a quitté
le théâtre des opérations pour regagner
Paris ou l'attendait les soucis de la
crise
[Musique]
c'est donc seulement le lendemain qu'il
reçut monsieur Pompidou venu lui
apporter la démission du gouvernement et
qu'il décidait de dissoudre l'Assemblée
en attendant les élections monsieur
Pompidou était maintenu dans ses
pouvoirs de Premier ministre
conformément à la Constitution le
général de Gaulle consultait le
président du Sénat monsieur moderville
et le président de l'Assemblée monsieur
chaban-delma il y aura donc des
élections législatives après le
référendum dont le président de la
République disait avec cette force et
cette émotion
quant à moi
chaque oui
de chacune de celle
de chacun de ceux qui me leur a donné
me sera la preuve directe
de sa confiance et ne son encouragement
ce sont donc vos réponses
qui me diront le 28 octobre
si je peux et si je dois
poursuivre en attache au service de la
France
vive la République vive la France
[Musique]
qu'un homme part effectuer 6 fois le
tour de la terre n'étonne plus personne
aujourd'hui Walter skyrin 9e cosmonaute
et 3e américain a tenté l'expérience n'a
donc pas fait alter les foules comme
l'avait fait Glenn ou Carpenter dans son
étroite cabine pourtant le compte à
rebours n'en fut pas moins
impressionnant
[Musique]
avait parfaitement enlevé la capsule
Mercury et ce qui rade déjà
s'entretenait avec Slayton au contrôle
de cap canavera
après avoir traversé les couches froides
de la haute atmosphère la cabine était
placée sur orbite ce qui rend
réussissait parfaitement ces six tours
de terre
le voyage de Lorette et d'assise pin-up
avait été le dernier pape à le faire en
1857 durant près de 100 ans ses
successeurs s'étaient interdit de
voyager en décidant de se rendre en
pèlerinage dans les deux cités italienne
Jean 23 a fait un geste qui peut passer
pour assez extraordinaire et qui prend
une importance toute spéciale à la
veille de l'ouverture du Concile
écumelique il devait s'en expliquer dans
la basilique de leur intensé perdre ce
pèlerinage s'ajoute à toutes les
supplications qui dans tous les temples
du monde d'Orient et d'Occident se sont
élevés vers Dieu pour un heureux
déroulement des grandes assises et
communiques en faveur de l'amour
fraternel de la paix de la grandeur de
la famille et du travail
[Musique]
le 49e Salon de l'automobile c'est
d'abord celui de la grande confrontation
européenne face au firs en anglais
italienne allemande qui ont notamment
engagé la bataille des petites voitures
pas de révolution des modèles éprouvés
améliorés chez les constructeurs
français chez Panhard la pl1763 a accru
la puissance de son moteur ses 4
vitesses sont synchronisées son capot
plongeant abrite la route secours
au-dessus du moteur la famille compte
désormais un break élégant espacieux et
version commercialisée du modèle
victorieux 24 Heures du Mans la CD
la Simca 1000 reste si l'on peut dire le
fer de lance de la firme de Poissy
grande habitabilité et dans le coffre
grand espace pour les bagages puissances
améliorer version de luxe métallisée
tels sont les caractéristiques du modèle
63 une nouveauté le coupé Simca 1000 car
sépare Bertone
chez Peugeot la 403 reste fermement
fidèle au rendez-vous la 404 offre
désormais une version familiale quant au
moteur à injection indirecte il équipe
les deux modèles de luxe de la firme le
cabriolet et le nouveau coupé 404 qui
attire les regards
les améliorations sur la gamme des RK
chez Renault une 6 cylindres 6 places la
ramblait
mais la nouveauté se trouve sous le
capot de la R8 comme sous celui de la
Dauphine la boîte de vitesse automatique
selon les nécessités de la route les
vitesses sont désormais laissées au
choix d'un cerveau électronique plus de
leviers de vitesse des touches comme sur
un poste de radio et seulement deux
pédales accélérateur et frein le
conducteur de demain sera un être comblé
pour le Prix de l'Arc de Triomphe c'est
le métro à l'heure de la sortie des
bureaux on s'y entasses pêle-mêle pour
apercevoir son favori parmi les deux
douzaines de concurrents qui prennent le
départ sur les 80000 spectateurs il y en
a tout de même quelques-uns pas beaucoup
qui aperçoivent de temps à autre le bout
de la queue d'un cheval pour notre
caméraman avec son œil à rallonge pas de
souci il suit la course comme dans un
fauteuil
[Musique]
en ligne droite c'est là que les
cardiaques risquent la crise on a parié
des milliards dans cette course c'est la
fortune pour ceux qui ont misé sur un
outsider s'il gagne bien entendu
jusqu'au poteau 4 chevaux donnent encore
des sueurs froides à leur supporter
c'est le plus grand des quatre chevaux
qui se dégagent à longue foulée dans les
derniers mètres c'est le numéro 14
sollicop on l'attendait pas mais il a
tout de même fait des heureux ceux qui
ont parié sur lui et qui touchent la
grosse côte le possesseur du billet
gagnant de la Loterie Nationale qui
empoche 200 millions et aussi sa
propriétaire madame del 2K qui gagne 84
millions et des poussières
[Musique]
que démarre les Français maillot foncé
devant les footballeurs anglais hfield
vif incisif virevoltant les Français
s'amusent de leurs adversaires qui
paraissent figés comme les tours d'un
château de sa gracieuse majesté
pas numéro 9 s'en donne à cœur
les autres buts on les a attendus mais
ils ne sont jamais venus ainsi petit à
petit les Anglais ont pu refaire le
terrain perdu et en deuxième mi-temps
ils ont parfois donné l'impression qu'il
jouait aussi bien que les Français
ce n'était là qu'une impression et comme
la chance était avec eux l'arbitre leur
a fait un petit cadeau en leur donnant à
penalty une aubaine que les Anglais
n'ont pas manqué mais qu'importe ce
match nul pour les Français qui sont
désormais repartis du bon pied
[Musique]
la France va se prononcer sur le mode
d'élection du président de la République
les bureaux des mairies ont été pris
d'assaut le nombre de ceux qui ont tenu
à régulariser leur situation de citoyens
à traduit l'importance de la prochaine
consultation pendant ce temps les
rotatifs débités les planches de Wii et
de nom oui ou non le président de la
République sera-t-il élu par tous les
citoyens si la réponse est positive elle
transformera la vie politique de l'État
pour comprendre la pensée du général de
Gaulle il convient d'interroger
l'histoire il y a 4 ans c'est à
l'unanimité ou presque que le général de
Gaulle a été appelé par le peuple
français et chacun se rappelle les
circonstances récentes dans lesquelles
la République et les libertés
démocratiques ont été en danger le chef
de l'État a pu alors agir grâce à cette
base populaire qui devait ensuite
largement approuver son action
or en 1914 à la veille de la Grande
Guerre Raymond Poincaré président de la
République avouait à un familier je suis
président de la République et je ne peux
rien faire
réélu en 1939 le président Albert Lebrun
ne pouvait trouver dans sa fonction
l'autorité indispensable devant la
conjoncture internationale
dans l'euphorie de la victoire en 1918
Paul Deschanel fut préféré par le
Congrès de Versailles à Clémenceau dont
le grand caractère effrayait
et lorsque Milan voulu faire prendre au
président de la République une part plus
active dans la politique du pays il fut
obligé d'y renoncer pour désigner le
successeur de Vincent Auriol il ne
fallut pas moins de 14 scrutins élus
dans de telles conditions à la suite de
multiples transactions de quelle
autorité pouvait se prévaloir un
président de la République
[Musique]
c'est cette autorité que le général de
Gaulle veut donner à son successeur et
pour cela il propose aux Français qui
auront un décider de lui apporter le
soutien massif et officiel du suffrage
universel ce soutien qu'il connaît lui
sous la forme de l'acclamation et du
consentement général
[Musique]
Bruxelles a vécu un dimanche agitée le
Comité d'action flamand pour Bruxelles
et la frontière linguistique avait
organisé une deuxième marche sur la
capitale
agitant l'emblème des Flandres les
marcheurs que les autorités ont estimé à
50 000 ont entrepris de traverser la
ville cette intrusion en masse n'a la
basse en provoquer les réactions des
contre manifestants francophones et
c'est ainsi qu'on allait très vite en
venir aux mains
[Applaudissements]
un certain point névralgique la
gendarmerie une forte affaire pour
séparer les antagonistes il y a eu des
blessés on en a relevé une vingtaine
c'est le bilan de la journée un bilan
trop lourd
[Applaudissements]
il fallut dit-on la nouvelle de la
victoire de l'équipe belge de football
sur la Hollande pour calmer les esprits
Bruxelles en tout cas souhaiterait
passer des dimanches plus calme
à vous on le entre la France et Monaco
rien ne va plus mais on n'entend pas
encore tonner les canons du château
autour de son port et de son rocher
Monaco a beaucoup grandi en disant non
en surface on y dispose que de 150
hectares mais en hauteur
et il semble bien que les building aient
poussé en fonction du nombre des
sociétés qui se sont installées dans ce
pays sans impôts autant dire de rêves
or ou réalise-t-elle tout naturellement
le gros de leur chiffre d'affaires en
France et en échappant au fils la
frontière est tellement symbolique le
fruitier est à Monaco le boulanger d'en
face dans les Alpes-Maritimes or en
pleine nuit un premier barrage de
douanier a été installé première mesure
de pression Monaco sera-t-il territoire
étranger où les négociations Franco
Monégasques suspendus reprendront-elles
pour aboutir à un accord fiscal
les mouvements de l'escadre de
Méditerranée faisait partie de la
dernière phase des grandes manœuvres
navales françaises dernière phase à
laquelle était venue assister le général
de Gaulle sur le porte-avion Clemenceau
le chef de l'État devait suivre le
déroulement d'une série d'exercices qui
commencèrent par le catapultage d'Alizée
d'Aquilon et des tenda
attaque du porte-avion riposte
ainsi ça je fais pour le Clemenceau et
une vingtaine de bâtiments de la Marine
nationale l'exercice Linois dont le
thème était la protection d'un convoi en
Méditerranée occidentale
cependant l'Auvergne ne tardait pas à se
voir assailli par des vagues successives
de parachutistes du parti rouge
le général de Gaulle était venu
également assister aux dernières
péripéties de l'opération Dassas seconde
phase des grandes manœuvres de l'armée
de terre
les rouges ayant fini par installer une
tête de pont au camp de la courtine au
parti bleu de les en déloger avec l'aide
des gendarmes et des réservistes cartel
était le but des manœuvres mettre en
œuvre la défense intérieure du
territoire on fit à cette occasion
connaissance avec le nouvel engin léger
du combat même arroser des sens
enflammer il poursuit ses évolutions
parfaitement à l'aise
[Musique]
le chou se porte cette saison sur la
tête d'une manière disons-le très
parisienne pour tout avouer c'est le nom
de la nouvelle ligne de coiffure à la
mode cheveux courts en plan superposé
symbrisant les uns dans les autres à la
façon des feuilles de chou une certaine
hauteur de casse comme on dit dans le
métier et voilà vous savez tout avec une
frange bande auréolant le front c'est le
style Grandjean interprété par Serge
sterre
[Musique]
ambulance raffinement avec un diadème
pour les grands soirs signés
Jean-Clément
[Musique]
hiératique avec la nostalgie de l'Egypte
c'est la coiffure Néfertiti de Fernand
Aubry
[Musique]
plan contrarié rajeunissement de la
ligne fin de siècle une interprétation
de gombo Saintonge
architecture compliquée avec un effet de
chignon fait de mèche savante Luc
traîneau a réussi une création
étonnamment jeune
enveloppante elle est la marque
d'Antoine Salvador mais attention il y a
chou et chou
[Musique]
pour 500 millions de catholiques c'est
l'événement du siècle qui a commencé à
Rome avec la procession vers la
basilique Saint-Pierre de 2400 paires de
l'église autrement dit de la
quasi-totalité des archevêques des
évêques des patriarches des supérieurs
d'ordre venus des quatre coins du monde
cette procession exceptionnelle près
ludette à l'ouverture par le pape Jean
XXII du concile écumenique une foule
immense de fidèles 300 000 la place
Saint-Pierre n'en contient pas plus
était là pour saluer le souverain pontif
[Musique]
un peu plus tard la grande nef de
Saint-Pierre offrait le spectacle du
pape et des pères rassemblés pour
débattre des questions qui intéressent
tout le monde catholique spectacle
rarissime puisque c'est la 21e fois
seulement dans l'histoire de l'Église
que le concile est réuni le dernier le
fut en 1869 l'avant-dernier au 16e
siècle
la journée devait s'achever par une
procession du Colisée à Saint-Pierre 10
000 flammes illuminèrent la place où
s'était retrouvé une foule aussi dense
au matin
de sa fenêtre Jean XXII donna sa
bénédiction fidèle ce fut là la première
grande journée du concile
[Musique]
Pleumeur-Bodou petit hameau de la région
de Lannion n'avait sans doute jamais
reçu le président de la République la
présence de la station de
télécommunication spatiale lui a valu en
même temps que la célébrité mondiale
cette réparation de l'histoire le
général de Gaulle est en effet venu
inaugurer officiellement la station
bretonne et admirait l'oreille géante
qui capte sous le radôme les ondes venus
des USA via le satellite telsta le
général de Gaulle avait du reste
personnellement rendez vous avec Telstar
ou du moins par son intermédiaire avec
l'ambassadeur de France aux États-Unis
c'était pour Monsieur Hervé alpha un
rendez-vous matinal à New York il était
5 heures du matin
[Musique]
l'approche du référendum s'est traduite
sur les murs et les panneaux électoraux
par les prises de position des
différentes formations politiques
de son côté le chef de l'État après
avoir rappelé les tâches que la nouvelle
Constitution lui avait permis de mener à
bien avec
comme la preuve est ainsi faite
de la valeur d'une constitution qui veut
que l'Etat est une tête
comme depuis que je joue ce rôle
personne n'a jamais pensé que le
Président de la République était là pour
autre chose
je crois en toute conscience
que le peuple doit maintenant
par un vote solaire
marquez qu'il veut qu'il en soit ainsi
aujourd'hui demain et plus tard
le tel des monnaies prépare l'ultime
offensif du nouveau franc fixé au 1er
janvier prochain à cette date ce sera en
effet officiellement la cohabitation des
anciens et des nouveaux francs il n'y
aura plus qu'un seul franc qui vaudra
simplement 100 centimes de nouvelles
pièces seront alors mises en circulation
50 centimes 20 centimes on retrouvera
aussi les deux souhaits le sous d'autres
fois un sou sera de nouveau un sous pour
longtemps espérant le
[Musique]
de la Colombie-Britannique à San
Francisco les habitants de la côte ouest
des États-Unis ont une fois de plus
constaté que l’océan Pacifique n'est pas
aussi débonnaire que son nom l'indique
des tornades venus de la mer ont déversé
sur le pays des tonnes d'eau durant 3
jours on a vu des escaliers transformés
en cascade et des autos en bateau 40
morts noyade ou accidents divers dual
inondation
un homme pourtant a gardé un moral à
toute épreuve ce gardien de stade a
profité de la pluie pour immêler des
produits chimiques et effectuer ainsi
son nettoyage
[Musique]
malgré le climat d'insécurité qui règne
au confins du Tibet en raison des
attaques chinoises certaines œuvres
d'assistance à l'enfance continuent à
apporter au petit garçon et aux petites
filles des plus hautes montagnes du
monde soins et enseignement
[Musique]
le Dalaï Lama vient parfois assez faites
infantines encouragées ceux qui
poursuivent leur mission éducatrice et
pour une seule année d'une telle
importance où le Dieu vivant apparaît en
public faite et dense célèbre
l'événement
[Musique]
le commerce des toit et autres
gouttières n'a pas empêché Marcel
Garnier plombier zinguer de son état de
cultiver aussi le commerce des Muses au
contraire peut-être à tel point en tout
cas qu'une envie la saisie devenir
immortelle quad plus naturel nous
l'avons interrogé sur cette audacieuse
tentation que vous avez posé récemment
votre candidature à l'Académie française
au fauteuil de Pierre Benoit exactement
et cette lettre je crois que vous l'avez
écrite en vert en alexandrin alors
écoutez monsieur Garnier et nous serions
très heureux si vous vouliez nous lire
voilà j'ai fait un rêve oubliez mon
adresse bon couvreur et plombier et
poète à la fois je voudrais parmi vous
très bientôt prendre place de venir
immortel en entrant par le toit
alors pour vous servir sur votre
couverture j'effaceterai les trous avec
du Viletta ce sera la paiement de ma
candidature et le prix d'un fauteuil
même d'un strapontin enfin bien habillé
de verre bicorne nantais j'entrerai près
de vous dans l'immortalité ayant un
institut ainsi fait la conquête là en
passionné au point et l'épée aux côtés
d'ores et déjà la candidature de Marcel
Garnier a été rejetée le Secrétaire
perpétuel a été net il y a eu vice de
forme revenus assez robinets il reste au
plombier poète à méditer sur la sévérité
du protocole
[Musique]
par certains de ses côtés le cinéma
s'apparente à la magie comme elle il
possède ses secrets pour faire rêver des
jeux de miroirs de lentilles de prisme
permettent aujourd'hui par exemple ses
effets saisissants de multiplication à
l'infini d'un sujet unique
[Musique]
une main et une rose c'est tout un balai
mais le magicien du film peut encore
faire plus donner le cadre du Mont Blanc
à des personnages installés le plus
prosaïquement du monde
dans un champ d'Île-de-France un dessin
une photo suffisent à créer l'illusion
il suffit de les placer dans le
Simplifilm un système optique mis au
point par Achille Dufour et qui se fixe
devant la caméra pour réaliser ce tour
de passe-passe
et deux personnages sur un sentier
auront l'air de passer sous la porte du
château de Blois
[Musique]
ainsi des géants pourront se profiler au
dessus des châteaux
de grandes étendues apocalyptiques
croyez vous en vérité une maquette de
très petite dimension on installera
aussi facilement un personnage sur un
doigt de la main que sur le dos d'une
gargouille
et on pourra faire danser un balai dans
le décor de l'Opéra sur un simple
plateau de studio depuis Méliès la
machinerie des magiciens du film c'est
notablement réduite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jouer à Vienne ce n'est jamais très rose
pour une équipe étrangère et la contre
elle non seulement l'équipe adverse mais
également les 50 000 excités des
tribunes près à n'importe quoi pourvu
que leurs favoris gagne les Rémois
maillot à manche blanche qui n'était pas
très rassurées lorsqu'ils ont entamé
leur match de Coupe d'Europe contre
Austria dans la capitale Autriche et il
n'avait pas tout à fait tort à peine 12
minutes de jus premier bu Autriche
[Applaudissements]
3 minutes plus tard Reims égalise sur
penalty que tire sauvage voilà qui est
fait
et puis les Autrichiens donnent des
frissons aux joueurs français mais rien
ne passe Colona arrête tout
[Applaudissements]
tout sauf admirable reprise de voler de
l'ailier droit autrichien sur corner
cela semble être le début de la
catastrophe pour Reims dans l'équipe de
surcroît est handicapé par l'expulsion
de son intergo jean Vincent pour
brutalité paraît-il alors que les
Autrichiens n'ont jamais cessé de
multiplier les provocations et Austria
se fait ainsi un troisième but
les joueurs français après avoir fourni
le pire redresse la barre et marque un
second but qui leur permet d'espérer que
tout n'est pas perdu pour le match
retour qui aura lieu à Paris cette fois
dans les 38 000 communes de France 27
millions d'électeurs ont choisi entre le
Wii que demander le général de Gaulle et
le nom que soutenait ses opposants que
ce soit dans les villages de province ou
les quartiers de la capitale française
et français ont eu à trancher au fond de
leur conscience le débat ouvert entre
les parties et le chef de l'État sur
l'élection au suffrage universel du
président de la République ce débat sa
sortie c'est à la vérité du souvenir des
erreurs passées de la crainte de
lendemain difficile il s'assortissait
également d'une passion que jusqu'ici
aucun autre référendum n'avait suscité
c'est dans cette ambiance un peu lourde
que les Français ont voté
à la mairie de Colombelles et deux
églises redevenues pour un moment simple
citoyen le général de Gaulle a comme
tout le monde déposé son bulletin
[Musique]
dès le soir aux Champs-Élysées les
Parisiens suivaient l'apparition
successive des résultats
fin de soirée au ministère de
l'Intérieur monsieur Roger frais faisait
devant les journalistes l'analyse du
scrutin
62,10% des suffrages pour le oui
37,90% pour le nom voici donc le général
de Gaulle confirmé au pouvoir à une
heure ou une crise ne pouvait avoir que
de fatals conséquences
[Musique]
l'amitié de la Finlande pour la France a
toujours été sincère et profonde a dit
Monsieur hour ok connaît au général de
Gaulle venus accueillir à Orly c'est
dans la chaleur de cette amitié que
devait se dérouler pendant trois jours
la première visite d'un président de la
République finlandaise à Paris visite
dont la partie officielle se termine par
le gala donné à l'Opéra et qui a réuni
autour de Monsieur kekanen et du général
de Gaulle les plus hautes personnalités
de l'État
au cours de l'histoire récente la France
et la Finlande ont eu l'occasion de
s'apprécier elles viennent à travers ce
voyage de souligner avec éclat qu'elles
entendent poursuivre cette amitié
[Musique]
le prix Nobel de littérature a été
décerné à John Steinbeck dont chacun se
rappelle certains titres des souris et
des hommes les vers pâturage et les
raisins de la colère entre autres c'est
la sixième fois que cette distinction
récompense en américain les derniers
furent folkner et Hemingway
dans un genre tout différent le prix des
Palmes d'or attribué annuellement à
Paris à un roman d'espionnage est allé à
Maurice Gabriel Braun pour sa dernière
œuvre apôtre de la violence Catherine
Langeais Mick Michel Félix Martens
ouvrage on ose plus dire qu'il promet
[Musique]
davantage encore d'étudiants à Paris
c'est à dire des problèmes accrus et
l'année a commencé par des
manifestations devant le vénérable
institut mille étudiants en médecine ont
réclamé des centres hospitaliers
universitaires
à la gare Saint-Lazare 200 autres
étudiants ont envahi la salle des pas
perdue pour s'y installer avec duvet et
couverture et attirer ainsi l'attention
sur le manque de logement
il fallut qu'elle énergies aux agents de
police pour résorber cet encombrement
supplémentaire à une heure de pointe
[Musique]
le monde avec une semaine dramatique en
mission de surveillance au-dessus de
Cuba les avions U2 américains
photographiés à la construction et
l'établissement de rampe de lancement de
fusée dont l'existence ne pouvait plus
passer pour une mesure défensive
or Cuba n'est en cas 200 km les côtes
américaines jusqu'à New York était
tenues sous le feu des fusées à courte
portée tandis que les engins à moyenne
portés menacaient les deux tiers des
territoires des États-Unis
c'est photographié allaient déclencher
l'alerte dans un discours imprévu le
président Kennedy dénonçait le péril ces
bases disaient-ils ne peuvent avoir
d'autres raisons que de fournir une
force de frappe nucléaire dirigée contre
nous
il lançait en même temps le poids de la
flotte américaine dans la balance en
décritant le blocus pour toute
équipement militaire offensive à
destination de Cuba or à ce même moment
25 Argos Soviétiques étaient déjà en
route quelle est-il sortir de la
rencontre les cargo accepteraient-ils le
contrôle tenterait-il de forcer le
passage les heures commençaient à se
faire lourdes sur la côte américaine les
radars étaient déjà en état d'aller on
suivait dans les caves des états majors
la marche des cargo dont certains
disaient-on étaient porteurs de fusées à
charge nucléaire or les consignes
étaient strictes si les cargo tentaient
de se soustraire au contrôle et
prétendait continuer leur chemin l'ordre
était de tirer
c'est dans cette atmosphère que le
Conseil de sécurité se réunit d'urgence
plein de l'URSS accusant les États-Unis
de piraterie par la bouche de Monsieur
zorine
plainte de Cuba
plainte des États-Unis par la voix de
Monsieur Stevens
dans le même temps alors l'Organisation
des États d'Amérique réunis en séance
extraordinaire la place de Cuba était
demeurée vide et celle des États-Unis
était occupé par le ministre des
Affaires étrangères monsieur Dean rosk
l'assemblée a prouvé les mesures
décidées pour faire face aux dangers
d'agression venant de Cuba
[Musique]
la fièvre était montée au paroxysme les
manifestations de masse pour conspuer
les États-Unis se succèdent
fidèle Castro lui-même va haranguer une
population fanatisée qui brandissait des
pancartes au slogan définitif
la mobilisation générale était déjà
entrée en cours on creusait des
tranchées sur les côtes les postes de
DCA gettaient dans le ciel vide
l'approche des bombardiers US et l'homme
de la rue reprenait l'uniforme
[Applaudissements]
de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique diverses
manifestations prenaient pour cible les
ambassades ou les organismes américains
l'une d'entre elles celle d'Alger
répondait à la toute jeune amitié
Algérie Cuba affiché depuis la visite de
Ben Bella à fidèle Castro
[Musique]
quel est-il sortir de cette fièvre
dangereuse
aguantanamo la base louée aux Américains
par Cuba pour 99 ans plusieurs milliers
de Marines étaient arrivés en renfort
[Applaudissements]
par contre femme et enfants étaient
évacuées tout était possible et puis le
miracle de la sagesse et de la fermeté
eu raison de la fatalité des dangers en
chaîne ruchev détourna ses cargo et
annonce à la destruction des rentes
reste tout de même Guantanamo donc
Castro réclame l'évacuation mais l'heure
du drame est passé
[Musique]
devant l'Allemagne de l'Ouest la
Stuttgart l'équipe de France de football
a confirmé son renouveau et pourtant
sans raie mon copain elle n'avait pas
l'air de grand chose au début du match
cette équipe de France pendant 25
minutes les solides allemands en maillot
blanc ont donné des sueurs froides aux
supporters français et pourtant c'est la
France qui marque le premier but par
stako
Hitchcock lui-même n'aurait pas mieux
régler le scénario
les Allemands cependant font encore
passer un très mauvais quart d'heure à
l'équipe de France et là on assiste à un
numéro de défense collective de très
grande place
[Applaudissements]
après cette période assez pénible les
avants Français reprennent tant mal les
opérations on assiste alors à quelques
actions pétillantes à un football plein
de gaieté qui serait irrésistible si les
joueurs français maintenaient cette
cadence durant tout le match quoi qu'il
en soit c'est au terme de l'une de ses
actions que la France marque son second
but
[Applaudissements]
deuxième mi-temps les Allemands forcent
la cadence à un moment où les Français
sont peut-être un peu trop décontractés
ou plus simplement un peu fatigué
[Applaudissements]
une nouvelle fois la défense est obligée
de jouer au coude à coup pour éviter le
pire ce qui n'empêche pas les Allemands
de marquer
[Applaudissements]
le but d'égalisation ne va pas tarder
mais ce match nul des Français les
centres voir des succès pour demain leur
première victime sera peut-être la
Hongrie le 11 novembre prochain à Paris
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]